THE MOVIE HOME TEAM AVAILABLE
FOR STREAMING THIS COMING
FRIDAY
ON NETFLIX. IT IS ABOUT
THE YEAR OFF
THAT SEAN PAYTON HAD FROM THE
NFL SUSPENDED.
AND IT FROM THE LEAGUE AND HE
WENT AND HE COACHED HIS KIDS
YOUTH FOOTBALL TEAM BASED
ON THE TRUE STORY IN THE MAN
WHO PLAYS SEAN, PAYTON
IN THE MOVIE IS HERE
ON THE RICH EYES AND SHOW THE
GREAT. KEVIN, JAMES. HOW YOU
DOING? KEVIN? GOOD, BUDDY. HOW
ARE YOU? I'M DOING FINE. SO
I'M JUST GOING TO GO STRAIGHT
IN AND ASKED THE MOST AWKWARD
QUESTION TO START THINGS OFF.
ARE YOU NOW?
NOW THE LEADING CANDIDATE
TO REPLACE SEAN. PAYTON?
PAYTON, AT THE NEW ORLEANS
SAINTS. ARE
YOU?
IS THAT THIS WOULD BE THIS
WOULD BE A
BRILLIANT THING.
IF I PULLED THIS OFF, AS A
PROMOTIONAL ITEM,
HAS A JETS FAN
I CAME IN, I LURED HIM IN.
YES.
YES. AND JUST KIND OF GOT THEM
AWAY WITH THIS MADE HIM DO
THIS MOVIE TOLD ME TO DO THIS
MOVIE AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
THAT'S CHANGING THINGS AND
TRYING TO GET IN THERE AND
PLANTING THESE SEEDS
AND JUST KIND OF TOLD
HIM. HE SHOULD RETIRE. THERE'S
OTHER OPTIONS OR JUST GET HIM
AWAY FROM THE SAINTS
AND
GREAT. YEAH.
CAME OUT OF NOWHERE. I WAS
ABOUT TO SAY KEVIN YOU'D HAVE
TO DO THAT 30 MORE
TIMES.
HELLO TO 30 OTHER COACHES LIKE
MAKE 30 MORE MOVIES ABOUT
THEIR LIVES.
YOU KNOW, I WILL BE AROUND
THEM,
YOU KNOW BURN THEM OUT, BURN
THEM OUT. HOWEVER YOU WANT
AND THEN GET HIM OUT. YOU HAVE
TO DO THAT 30 MORE TIMES
DAILY ROUTINES. WELL WHO SAYS,
I'M NOT
KNOW WHAT I'M WORKING ON OTHER
PROJECTS AS YOU CAN TAKE SOME
TIME.
I MIGHT NOT SEE IT, BUT MY
KIDS WILL SEE THE JETS WIN.
IT'S A SLOW BURN, WE CALL THAT
A SLOW BURN,
RIGHT?
I KNOW.
HOW WILD IS THAT? HUH?
BUT GREAT.
SAINT, YOU KNOW, THIS IS KIND
OF CRAZY,
YOU KNOW MEAN OUT OF NOWHERE
TO ME. I HONESTLY, I DIDN'T
KNOW.
NO IDEA,
YOU KNOW, IT JUST, I DON'T
KNOW. I HAVE NO, I GUESS IT
WILL BE REVEALED. WHY OR WHAT
WHAT? I DON'T KNOW. WELL, YOU
JUST SAID HE JUST SAID, IT WAS
KIND OF TIME TO STEP AWAY
AND I THINK IT'S, YOU KNOW,
YOU'VE BEEN AROUND THIS
BUSINESS QUITE A BIT KEVIN.
MAYBE THE GREATEST
PROMOTIONAL
WAY TO GET EVERYBODY TO SEE
YOUR MOVIE ABOUT YOU
AND HISTORY OF PROMOTIONAL
PLOYS, YOU KNOW, LET ME TELL
YOU SOMETHING. I'LL TAKE IT. I
WILL TAKE,
BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, I THINK I HAD
NOTHING TO DO.
WITH, I DON'T KNOW.
I MEAN IT'S
MAYBE MAYBE IT IS MAYBE MY
MOVIE WAS SO BAD THAT
YOU THINK DO YOU THINK?
THINK
THAT'S NOT THE MOVIE? THE
MOVIE IS GOOD.
I'M SURE THE MOVIES, GREAT.
YES, BUT I'M SAYING MAYBE
THAT'S LIKE
COULD THINK OF THAT YOU HEAR
THE GREATEST NEWS THAT
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD NEWS. YOU
HEAR
SOMEBODY'S MAKING A MOVIE
ABOUT YOUR LIFE
AND YOU'RE LIKE WOW, HOW DOES
IT GET BETTER FROM THERE?
AND HE SAYS WHO'S
PLAYING ME? IS IT MATT
DAMON OR
DICAPRIO?
YOU AND YOU GO, HOLD ON. NO.
NO, IT'S NONE OF THOSE GUYS
HAVE BEEN JAMES
AND THEN YOU JUST KIND OF GO.
OKAY. I GOT TO RETHINK MY
LIFE.
I QUIT.
HOLD ON A SECOND. HOW ABOUT
THIS? BECAUSE THIS FILM
HOME TEAM AGAIN AS STREAMING
AVAILABLE STARTING ON FRIDAY.
WHEN NETFLIX
ABOUT HIS ONE YEAR
AWAY FROM THE SAINTS.
HE'S NOW CREATED ANOTHER
YEAR AWAY.
THE SAINTS?
THUS A SEQUEL.
ALREADY BAKED IN
HOME, TEAM
TO ON NETFLIX AT SOME
POINT. YOUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT
THAT. I AM. SO IN THIS IS
CRAZY
RICH EISEN. I DID NOT PUT THIS
TOGETHER. YOU DID. HOW ABOUT
THAT? THEY,
YOU MUST BE SOMEHOW YOU NEED
TO BE INCLUDED SOMEHOW.
I DO LIKE IT. I LIKE IT. YES.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE PEOPLE OF
NEW ORLEANS ARE GOING TO LIKE
IT
BUT
WELL, LET'S JUMP.
JUMP INTO THIS ONE.
SO
OBVIOUSLY
YOUR JET FAN AND
A FOOTBALL FAN. SO YOU YOU
KNOW, YOU REMEMBER WHEN
SEAN PAYTON
WAS TOLD BY THE LEAGUE, YOU
GOT TO SIT OUT FOR A YEAR.
YEP,
SO, YOU KNOW, THE STORY, HOW
IS THIS BROUGHT TO YOU AS
AN IDEA, YOU KNOW YOU
PLAYING SEAN PAYTON IN THIS
MOVIE. HOW IS THAT CENTRAL TO
YOU? MA'AM? I BROUGHT IT TO
ME, SANDLER, BROUGHT THE IDEA
TO ME
AND II DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
I DID, YOU KNOW, ABOUT THAT,
BY THE WAY, I NEED. YEAH. I
MEAN
I'M SAYING ABOUT THIS.
ENGINE. AND I REMEMBER, YOU
KNOW,
WRITE THE WHOLE THING BACK IN
THE DAY,
BUT I DIDN'T KNOW THERE WAS A
YEAR WHERE HE WAS SUSPENDED. I
DIDN'T REMEMBER THAT WAS THE
PUNISHMENT, AND THEY DIDN'T
KNOW HE WENT HOME DEPTH
AND RECONNECT WITH ASCENDANT
SORT OF COACHING HIS KIDS
FOOTBALL TEAM AND TOOK HIM TO
THE CHAMPIONSHIP WHICH WAS
IT WAS, YOU KNOW, AN AMAZING
TIME. HE'S LIKE, IT'S, HE SAID
THE GREATEST SEASON OF
COACHING
IN HIS CAREER, WHICH I THINK,
LET'S BE HONEST, THE SUPER
BOWL.
HE'S CLEARLY LYING BUT
S, S THE KID, RIGHT?
THAT CAN YOU GET THEIR HOME TO
YOUR KIDS THAT S FOR SURE.
YES,
BUT NO WEIRD ONE. YES,
BEATS A SUPER BOWL. I DON'T
CARE. WHAT WHO, YOU KNOW,
WE ALL KNOW THAT,
SO
I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THAT, BUT
THAT WAS SUCH AN INTERESTING
STORY TO ME. THE STORY WAS
JUST,
I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT WAS
ACTUALLY
TRUE THAT HE DID THAT, AND
IT JUST SEEMED LIKE A
PERFECTLY
GREAT
SPORTS FAMILY MOVIE TO MAKE. I
MEAN, I WAS LIKE, I COULDN'T
BELIEVE IT WASN'T DONE. AND
WASN'T DONE AND I WAS, I
JUMPED IN, YOU JUMPED
IN. SO
SANDLER, BRINGS IT TO YOU.
AT, WHAT POINT? WERE YOU
BROUGHT OR
TO PEYTON OR PEYTON TO YOU
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
ALL OF? WELL, THAT WAS ONE OF
THE THING I SAID IS SEAN IN
BECAUSE IT FEELS WEIRD TO BE
DOING A STORY ABOUT HIS LIFE.
YES. HE'S IN HE'S IN
AND
YOU KNOW, HE WAS, HE WAS
GREAT. HE WAS
KRISTA TONE. WHO IS WHO
IS ACTUALLY IT'S A WHOLE
CONVOLUTED. IT'S A LITTLE
STORY THAT
THEY'RE HIM. AND
TAYLOR LAUTNER, OUR FRIENDS
WITH
SEAN AND,
AND CHRIS DATES
MEGAN WHO'S SEAN'S DAUGHTER
AND THIS AND THAT. SO THEY
WERE ALL IN THE WORKINGS OF
THIS THING,
MEGHAN PRODUCE. THE PIECE
CALLED CUTTING ORANGES, WHICH
WAS LIKE A SMALL
DOCUMENTARY PIECE
ON
SHOWING COACHING THIS TEAM AND
THAT'S WHAT WE SAW IN BASED AT
ALL ON AND
AND IT WAS SUCH A GREAT STORY
THAT YEAH, HE WOULD SEAN WAS
IN
AND I WENT OUT THERE AND HE
COULDN'T HAVE BEEN BETTER WITH
MEMA. HE TOOK ME THROUGH
EVERYTHING.
HE TOOK ME TO THE SAME
FACILITY.
SHOWED ME
EVERYTHING WAS GOING ON. I GOT
TO SEE HOW HE OPERATES. WHAT
HE DOES AND TRY TO
TAKE WHAT I COULD AND PUT SOME
STUFF IN THE MOVIE. AND YOU
KNOW, IT'S ALSO LIKE A
BAD NEWS, BEARS TYPE MOVIE.
IT'S REALLY DIDN'T HAVE MUCH
TO DO WITH THE SAINTS,
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
SUSPENSION, REALLY? IT HAS TO
DO WITH ALL
TOOK PLACE AFTER, AND IT WAS
YOU KNOW, THAT'S WHAT, YOU
KNOW, EXCITED ME. THAT'S SO
COOL, MAN. SO I DO
REMEMBER, KEVIN, I DO REMEMBER
THAT
DOCUMENTARY, RIGHT? I DO
REMEMBER THAT, THAT
HIS
DAUGHTER PUT TOGETHER, RIGHT?
SO THAT WAS THE
THE
THE BASIS IN THE GENESIS OF
SOMETHING. YES, TO PUT IT
TOGETHER
AND AND THEN SO THE DRAFT.
SO YOU SAW I MEAN LOOK, I MEAN
THE MAN STEPS AWAY FROM A
COACHING GIG AFTER ALL THE
TIME. SO YOU SAW THE GRIND.
I MEAN YOU SAW LIKE
A THAT'S A SERIOUS TIME OF
YEAR, BUT YOU ALSO SAW I'M
SURE HOW COOL AND CHILL HE IS
WHICH IS KIND OF CRAZY FRUIT
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE GRIND. I
MEAN, YOU PROBABLY SAW
EVERYBODY WAS COMING UP TO HIM
AND EVERYBODY,
EVERYBODY YOU KNOW, YOU SEE
AND HE MAKES DECISIONS,
YOU KNOW, LIKE YOU JUST SEE
WHAT A PRO
HE IS. HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S
DOING.
SO,
YOU KNOW,
I WAS JUST ASKING THEM
QUESTIONS ABOUT MY JETS AND
THAT WAS
HOW WE GONNA
FARE AND
HE WAS, HE WAS VERY KIND OF
WITH THAT.
AND YOU GUYS, YOU GUYS WILL BE
OKAY. HE WAS WRONG. WE
WANT OKAY THE SEASON,
YOU KNOW, BUT
YOU KNOW,
HE
WAS AMAZING AND HE WAS HE WAS
HE'S FUNNY. HE'S A GREAT.
GUY,
GREAT LEADER. AND YOU GET TO
SEE HOW HE OPERATES. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT I TOOK.
TRIED TO GET HIS ACCENT DOWN.
HIS ACCENT IS ALL OVER THE
JOINT. SO, MINE IS KIND OF
ALL HE'S GOT LIKE A LITTLE BIT
OF A SOUTHERN.
YEAH, DRAUGHT LIKE
SOMETIMES. BUT HE'S FROM
CALIFORNIA
AND THEN HE'S,
HE'S
A BIT STUFFY. HE
ADMITTED STUFF AND HE WAS ON
SET WATCHING ME AND I WAS
LIKE, I CAN'T DO THIS. NO,
REALLY MAN. HE'S LIKE REALLY
LIKE DON'T WORRY. YEAH. HE
HE-HE'S
IN STUFF. TRY TO LOCK HIM
DOWN. I COULDN'T GET HIM DOWN
BECAUSE HE'LL
BOUNCE IN.
I KNOW HE I MEAN AND IT CUZ
I MEAN, I GUESS IF YOU'RE
LIVING IN THE BAYOU FOR
16 YEARS,
WRITING KIND OF YOU KIND OF
ADOPT IT IN A WAY.
YEAH, AND
DID SHE DITCH? NOT HER SCREAM,
YOU CAN DO IT TO HIM AT ANY
POINT IN TIME. I MEAN,
I DON'T THINK IT MADE IT INTO
THE MOVIE. IT FELT LIKE IT WAS
NOT PART OF THIS MOVIE, BUT
IT WOULD BE, HE DID.
I THINK HE'S GOT TO DO THAT
EVERYWHERE.
I THINK IT IS. YES, IT IS. IT
IS IT IS WHAT AMERICA
REALLY WANTS KEVIN, YOU KNOW,
FROM ROB SCHNEIDER. I GOT
KEVIN JAMES HERE, HUH?
HOME TEAM AVAILABLE
IS AMAZING AND IT WAS GREAT.
HE'S FANTASTIC. WELL, I MEAN,
THIS IS, THIS IS GREAT. I
MEAN, SOME OF THE
SANDLER GANG IT PUT BACK
TOGETHER
FOR A MOVIE WITH
WITH WHILE HIS WIFE IS IN A TO
RIGHT JACKIE'S INTO
MY
AND SNYDER'S CURRENT,
WIFE. BUT
YEAH, OKAY. JUST
HOW AN ATOM WAS.
WE'RE THIS IS ALL COOL. RIGHT?
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY
I WAS EX-WIFE
EX-WIFE
MORON SCHNEIDER BECAUSE I
TRIED TO KISS HER, I GUESS. SO
I WAS LIKE, ALRIGHT, THAT'S UP
TO YOU, MAN. I LIKE
WORKING.
OH MY GOD. IT'S AVAILABLE FOR
AGAIN. STREAMING THIS COMING
FRIDAY, ON NETFLIX
HOME TEAM. KEVIN JAMES HERE ON
THE RICH EISEN SHOW. SO OKAY.
THIS IS GREAT MAN, AND SO DID
PEYTON PROBABLY LOVED
EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE, HE
MUST HAVE KNOWN EVERYTHING
THAT YOU DID, BECAUSE HE'S
LOCKED IN. I'M WATCHING THINGS
AND MOVIES AND TV, AND
YOU MUST HAVE BEEN VERY
WELL-VERSED ON EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DONE. HE LOVES,
LOVES, WE HAD A FUN.
TIME, HE'S GREAT, MAN.
I REALLY I HOPEFULLY I WISH IT
WAS AN HONOR TO PLAY. MMM, AND
I WISH HIM THE BEST. I'M
TELLING YOU KEVIN. IF THERE IS
A MOVIE ABOUT HIS SECOND YEAR
OFF FROM THE NFL, YOU WANT TO
GET IN ON THAT BECAUSE I THINK
HE'S ABOUT TO LIVE AT THE VIDA
LOCA
OVER THE
NIGHT EGRET YEAR.
I THINK HE IS ABOUT IT. HE IS
ABOUT TO GO DO THAT. ALL
RIGHT, MAN. WELL, THANKS FOR
THE TIME.
CONGRATS ON THIS. I CAN'T WAIT
TO SEE IT.
I KNOW THEM. I KNOW THE STORY.
AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S A
NICE FUN
STORY TO TELL, BUT
ALSO,
YOU KNOW, NICE AND COOL IN THE
WAY THAT ALL WORKS OUT
AND HOW
CAN'T WAIT TO THANK YOU RICH
ANY TIME. KEVIN YOU BE WELL,
APPRECIATE
IT BUD, RIGHT? BACK AT YOU.
THAT'S KEVIN. JAMES, AT KEVIN
JAMES ON TWITTER,
KEVIN JAMES OFFICIAL ON
INSTAGRAM RIGHT HERE IN THE